une carcasse de voiture brûlée est juste
à côté la façade noircie d'un immeuble à
la voiture calcinée dans ce quartier
paisible de marsannay la côte
l'incendié s'est déclaré peu avant
minuit un habitant de la résidence
raconte vers les 11h30
on a entendu les explosions donc j'ai
tout de suite su que c'était d'être une
voiture qui éclatait donc on a tout de
suite regardé là on a vu ton que la
voiture en bas qui prenait feu et une
deuxième voiture qui étaient aussi en
flammes donc la première chose on était
sur lui avec des voisins pour aider la
personne qui était handicapée dans
l'appartement
on a cassé les volets la fenêtre tous
les résidents de l'immeuble ont
finalement été évacués par les pompiers
la plupart d'entre eux ont pu regagner
leur appartement mais quatre ont dû être
relogés les habitants ont indiqué avoir
vu deux personnes s'enfuir après le
départ de feu le maire lui dénonce déjà
à demi mots un acte volontaire
c'est toujours les mêmes personnes qui
subissent les dégradations et ça ça
devient complètement intolérables
intolérable alors effectivement je
comprends je soutiens également mes
collègues mais en qui vivent ce genre de
situation mais on doit pas porter ça
tout seul il ya quand même des choses à
faire au niveau de l'état une enquête
est en cours pour déterminer les causes
de l'incendié elle a été confiée à la
gendarmerie de gevrey chambertin